On my mark, it will be t -five seconds.
September 25th, 1967.
A thor-agena rocket carrying a Corona
satellite takes to the skies from Vandenberg
Air Force Base in California.
Corona is an amazing program for its day.
Launching something into space period was a
brand new concept.
It was a real game changer because now it
allowed American spy satellites to traverse
airspace undetected and take very high
resolution photographs of anything they
wanted to.
Two years into its mission, as the spy bird
scans western Poland, it captures this image.
Among this really heavily wooded forest are
concrete structures.
This looks like a whole complex, almost like
a mini city here.
The fact that a spy satellite was designated
to photograph this means it ain't no Girl
Scout camp. We're probably looking at
something that was of significant national
security interest to the United States
military.
Yet declassified CIA documents reveal the
massive structures baffled their top
analysts. Investigators turned to recent
satellite images.
It just deepens the mystery as far as I'm
concerned.
In one era, these structures are visible to
satellites.
And in another the forest has reclaimed them
and overgrown them.
What is under these trees?
Why did somebody build something so big and
then just abandon it for decades?
Intrigued by what could lie in the forest.
Polish archaeologist Gregor Kikvidze is
traveling to the site in the satellite
images.
Something could be concealed in the dense
forest.
Then it raises the question about why CIA
was interested specifically in that place.
To find out. I need to go there and see what
features survived until the present day.
During World War Two, the Nazis build
concentration camps in Poland's forests.
After the war, this vast woodland falls
under the dark shadow of Soviet communism.
It looks like we are here.
To locate up close what the CIA were looking
at from space.
Kiyoshi is turning to the latest aerial
technology.
Maybe when we look from above, we will see
more.
The drone uses laser pulses to scan the
forest, effectively stripping away the canopy
to create a LiDAR image of what lies
beneath.
And for the first time in decades, the
mystery structure is mapped in detail.
It tells me that there is lots of remains
around in the landscape.
This is very interesting.
Kiyoshi heads towards the first of the
features revealed in the leader image.
Moving north, An unusual feature in the
forest floor catches the archaeologists eye.
This looks like a trend.
The presence of a trench suggests that
whatever was kept here needed protection from
ground assault.
And the LIDAR data reveals this was just one
of many trenches surrounding the central
structures.
This shows that whatever was kept in this
zone had to be secured for all the time.
Yet when Chavez gets closer to the central
zone, the mystery of what took place here
deepens. Oh, God.
The forest floor is littered with decaying
personal possessions.
Some belong to women and young children.
As Kirschvink explores further, he finds
chilling clues to what may have happened to
them. The macabre collection
sheds light on who the structures were built
for and when.
Look what they found. That was a Soviet army
uniform, and that's original
bottom. This is a bag and there is a date
inside.
It's 1982.
All those artifacts are not only evidence of
presence of Soviet soldiers, but also whole
Russian families here.
As Chavez pushes further into the forest, he
spots one of the large structures that
intrigued and mystified the CIA during the
Cold War.
Oh, God.
It looks like there is a little opening on
the side.
Maybe we can get into it and explore.
Oh, God.
One of the larger rooms yields clues to what
the Russians were doing here.
And the both sides of this room were very
thick blast proof doors.
And there are some relics of a ventilation
system.
Whatever was kept here required very
specific conditions.
The temperature and the humidity had to be
controlled for all the time.
In a blast proof chamber, the archaeologists
spot some artifacts on the floor.
Okay, so.
Those are seals.
As an expert of the Cold War, Chavez thinks
he recognizes this type of seal.
I'm pretty sure that those were used to seal
containers with nuclear warheads.
He visits aerial data has uncovered a secret
facility capable of securing a massive
stockpile of the most devastating weapons
known to mankind.
But something about the size and shape of
the missiles kept here is unusual.
The storage rooms are actually quite small,
which tells me that they could be used only
for storage of tactical nuclear warheads.
Tactical nuclear weapons can unleash a
destructive force 20 times more powerful than
the bomb that destroyed Hiroshima.
But what's even more terrifying is how
they're used.
The Cold War is well known for the threat of
the use of nuclear weapons.
Tactical nuclear weapon would be used in the
presence of your own troops on a battlefield.
The use of tactical nuclear weapons on a
battlefield is almost unimaginable.
With the push of a button, commanders
devastate key targets before deploying
thousands of troops to fight it out on an
apocalyptic radioactive landscape.
Imagine the reality of combat where everyone
is from head to toe.
Their nuclear protective suits using machine
guns and their lobbing tactical nuclear
weapons at one another.
All the while.
Recovered Cold War files reveal that in the
late 1960s, the Kremlin secretly moved dozens
of nuclear missiles to the site in the
image.
Just a few hundred miles from the Soviet
controlled border with Western Europe.
They disguise the missile bunkers and
surround the compound with barracks housing
young families.
The Soviet Union wasn't stupid.
They knew that we were watching.
The Soviets work hard to make this look like
just an ordinary military base, concealing
the fact that there are tactical nuclear
weapons stored all over the place.
It was well hidden in the woods, and it was
well kept from the people who lived nearby.
From here. It seems the Communists intended
to wage nuclear war.
The war to end all wars.
Yet Viz's investigation reveals that this is
just one element of the Soviet subterfuge.
This was a true Armageddon bunker.
Just proof that there was nuclear weapon kept
within the territories of Poland.
And another proof that people lived once in
the shade of nuclear holocaust.
For over three decades, the secret site
remains primed to unleash nuclear hell on
European cities and American bases just over
the border.
They have no idea that in the woods there are
all these nuclear weapons, and so their lives
could change like that in one moment.
Following the collapse of the Soviet Union,
the Soviet soldiers and their families
abandoned the site, leaving the area strewn
with their belongings and equipment.
Over the following years.
The clandestine base is reclaimed by the
forest, only to be revealed from the skies
once more.
The truth about this facility has only just
emerged.
And it makes me wonder.
What else is out there?